i always say that you know when your
startup in hyper growth
every quarter it's a different company
different company and different
challenges
you get more people so it's different
people
the company is different position so you
have different challenges
so when we started insight it was about
like you know building the product
then it was about being able to sell it
then it was about
you know managing existing customers and
every you know every step of the way
it was something completely different
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by home adventures hippo
insurance opposed labs synergy global
hello at stanford leap birthright excel
serena partners and in media partnership
with c-tech
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders another great founder's story
meet alona vadz the co-founder of
insights a startup focused on providing
intelligence about adversaries and
preventing cyber attacks before they
take place it was sold this year for 350
million dollars to rapid seven during
this time he took various leadership
roles in strategy product business and
engineering he is also involved in
social impact founding can fake kessif a
non-profit that promotes financial
literacy and lately step to tech that
brings a diversity to the high-tech
industry alone is an active angel
investor investing and advising founders
in various sectors
alon arvat welcome to 20 minute leaders
thank you so much for being with me
today how are you
i'm doing great i'm doing great
i'm really really honored to have you
here you know
hearing another inspiring founder's
journey a huge pride in the israeli
ecosystem you're a co-founder at
insights held a variety of really
interesting positions there and i'm
looking forward to hearing sort of your
own personal transition you know within
the seven years that you spent there now
today you're a senior director of
product management at rapid7 but within
insights you were vp of intelligence and
then chief product officer and then
chief strategy officer while also being
the general general manager of of the
israel branch and so you know really
fascinating journey that also begins you
know more on the social side with cyber
security working with teenagers in a
cyber school and and and paying back so
i think that there a lot of for us to
unpack and talk about alon and i'd like
to get started by getting to know you
better so so who is alone in your mind
yeah
so i think you know um
something that is very basic you know
with everything i do and all you know my
various experience
is my
passion and love for creation
for creating something new that didn't
exist before you know like my baby that
i'm responsible for bringing him
to the world and that's what you know
drives me every day when i wake up in
the morning you know building something
new making it better you know
contributing to society
this is what you know drasmone on a
regular basis and it started you know in
a very young age you know when i was in
high school i was looked for you know
new ventures and new initiatives um and
it also you know went with me you know
afterwards after my military service
when i founded cyber school uh which was
a company for cyber security training
education we even did some cyber some
cyber camps in the summer
for teenagers and later on with insights
and so
the the combination of cyber and
starting the cyber school what was the
motivation there you know what led you
know i know most most people that are
dealing with cyber especially after
their military service you know they're
occupied with withholding one or more
positions in cyber companies making good
amounts of money and working on products
that are a little bit distanced from the
human factor it requires to start a
cyber school
yeah so actually cyber school was
combining you know two very big passions
that i had one is for education so i've
been to education since high school and
also before cyber school i founded a
non-profit
it's called a wings of money for
financial literacy for teenagers so
education always been part of my life
and also cyber security ever since i
went to
the idf and i served in a200 and was
involved in all types of cyber
operations
i found cyber very exciting so cyber 2
was really combining this together
into one place and one initiative
but
actually i think you know what really
you know
sparked it you know and led to funding a
cyber school is the fact that my
co-founder guy he was on a trip
to northern israel and he met the family
there
and they asked him you know what are you
doing live so he said oh i'm doing cyber
security i said wow we wish that our son
would also study cyber security and this
is the point where we realized that
there is a very very big need in the
market
and that there is an opportunity and we
can be the ones without background from
cyber security from education to bring a
solution and help teenagers and their
parents you know get to know cyber
security
beautiful but but your contribution to
society wasn't limited to that because
then you went to start confey kessif as
the co-founder and ceo and then as a
board member that you're actually
talking about financial literacy not
cyber literacy
right
so
the financial literacy um actually came
from my from university so in university
i studied law and accounting
and i also come from accountants home so
both of my parents are
economist and an accountant
and i just felt that the things that i
learned in the first few weeks
of accounting in university is something
that anyone should know
and i said i can't believe that i
finished like 12 years
in school and i've never learned this
type of things so for me i said wow i
have to create
some organization that would bring this
knowledge to teenagers and allow them to
you know manage their money a lot better
which is a basic skill
right i think that that makes a lot of
sense now if you had to look back at
you know both the cyber school and confe
ksf and you know sort of
group them together as a part of your
life how do you look back on those
experiences what have you gained how do
you how to react to those experiences
today especially after going through the
hectic journey of of a startup that ends
up being very very successful getting
acquired for almost 400 million dollars
yeah so i i used to say that confetti
ksf and cyber school were my mba
so think of me like
yeah my so think of me the person that
had no idea what is business what is
funding a company how you sell something
how you work with customers i had no
idea
and with config sf and cyber school this
was for me and a way to jump into the
water and get into building something
building a company building a business
and that is actually what gave me a lot
of the confidence
and skill
to later on found inside which was like
a company of a lot bigger scale
but that was you know where i got my my
basics
incredible okay so we know the end
result of insights and we know that it's
very well connected to your background
in the military but also in cyber school
and through an mba-like experience
through both the cyber school and config
sf the founding story of of insight and
then i'd love to unpack a little bit on
your personal journey within this
company and what you've learned about
yourself as you're progressing into this
multinational company that ends up
selling for quite a lot of money right
so i think we had an extremely naive
beginning for insights so today i work a
lot with young entrepreneurs so i work
with them on
market analysis interviewing customers
understanding you know the size of the
market the tam
forming like a go-to-market strategy
we came from a completely naive position
you know we identified the problem
back then consuming intelligence about
you know threats and potential attacks
was extremely extremely manual process
hard to consume never on time and he
wanted to bridge this gap with
technology and product that would help
you consume that a lot easier
and we just you know found the team
started developing the product and start
approaching customers this is what we
did until one day someone approached say
hey why don't you raise capital we said
well that might be a good idea he said i
can connect it to someone okay let's
meet and we just came for a pitch with
no presentation
just like you know proof of concept that
we built in our garage and started
talking to pilot capital
and
they really loved the idea
and this is how it all rolled out
so we came from you know a position of
extremely you know naive people that
want to build something build something
great solve a problem to customers big
problem
but
it wasn't about you know how to build a
startup and how to build a pitch and how
you raise capital it came from very very
like naive and maybe even pure
position
unbelievable
you know paint me the picture that
you're sitting in this meeting
with glilot and your you know a group of
friends that are understanding this idea
but obviously you're not coming in ready
to fundraise and coming with the terms
and negotiations and and all of a sudden
you find yourself a great partner you
know out of the blue what what is that
experience like for both you as an
individual but also you as a team
yeah
so honestly
it was
mainly scary
honestly so like you know think of me as
a person
you know that didn't come from even the
high-tech industry right right not to
mention startup and entrepreneurship in
the high-tech industry by the way i'm
saying
after so you have to be careful with
what you're saying
yeah
he probably knows that but you know
coming to investors tell them hey i want
you to give me two million dollars
that was for me you know
unheard of you know no way i can do that
and
and i think that was like you know the
basic you know feeling i was really
doing it on the tip of my toes me and my
co-founders you know step by step trying
to figure out you know what to do next
what should we say you know we started
something consulting with people so we
began to understand better how it works
uh but it was really like you know
on the tip of photos
a bit scary you know how we're going to
do it and that was the feeling
i i love it so you're
obviously you're embarking on this great
journey with great partners great
friends a great mission and a great
technology
what's happening over these next seven
years like looking back what what what
experiences jump out at you and that
you're saying wow i'll take these with
me forever and these are the stories
that i'll tell my grandkids
yeah so there are a lot i always say
that
you know when your startup in hyper
growth
every quarter it's a different company
different company and different
challenges
you get more people since different
people
the company is different position they
have different challenges
so when we start insights it was about
like you know building the product
then it was about being able to sell it
then it was about you know managing
existing customers and every you know
every step of the way
it was something completely different
and you know for me it was you know all
these
steps of the way all these phases each
of them
built me and built another layer of my
personality this is how i feel
i think but
probably my biggest challenge
was when we became a relatively big
company in almost 200 employees
and we had over 10
executives
you know all across the globe and
creating alignment between all these
executives and teams that's been a huge
challenge
and and you know we went through like a
very long process that i led as chief
strategy officer
to really create alignment in the
strategy across all organization so the
product is developing
the market our marketing
the sales are also pitching to customers
and we work as a well-oiled machine
and think that in many ways my journey
is is in a way the story of insights
because in the way at the beginning it
was very much about providing like
intelligence towards the intelligence
right
where i said it's with intelligence
later on it was building a holistic
product that will also deal with
remediation and response adding
additional products building a r d that
would create high quality products in
regular cadence et cetera et cetera et
cetera and when we grew big
it was about creating clear strategy
alignment between all the different
functions in the organization
okay and also ability to scale our goal
to market and this is where i was also
responsible for strategic partnerships
right i think that that makes a lot of
sense and
the the progression that that you're
describing here
not a natural progression i can't
imagine it was a trivial decision for
you to transition from the intelligence
to the product to the strategy
what adjustments did you have to make
yourself as an entrepreneur as now an
executive in a multi
hundreds of people company
as you're you know changing your your
personal position and your personal
thinking process in your day-to-day
yeah it's a big challenge i have to say
i think that the most important tool and
the most important tip that i have to
give entrepreneurs and i tell it to
young entrepreneurs that i help all the
time
you know trust your judgment common
sense
is your most important tool in your
toolbox
right so
be open to change
try to understand the reality the
situation
and then trust your common sense
you're a smart person
right you know the business best you
know the situation best because you're
inside that day and night 24 7
and
trust your judgment to make the right
decision
and go with it i can tell that for me i
can remember situation remember where i
stood
who i talked to on the phone where i had
to make like a big decision
and and i made it
but you know in my mind
i was saying to myself wow how can you
trust yourself to do that you've never
done it before
it's the first time you're tackling this
type of decision how can you trust your
judgment you know related to new
products go to market strategy and what
i found in the end
that you know best the situation the
company the market
trust your common sense
incredible what what surprised you about
growing from three four five people all
the way to 200 people what what
surprised you about this journey that if
you were to listen that if you were to
think about it you know
of you back then you were like okay
alone back then didn't realize this is
how it works and now you do
yeah
it's a very good question i think it
really goes back to
the alignment
because where you're a young startup
alignment is a non-issue everyone sits
in the same room everyone are you know
have this this mission in front of them
and they go with that and they talk all
the time and there was a line
right i think something which really
surprised me is the importance of
alignment and communication
when you grow big
you have to communicate all the time
what you do
why you do it and create ceremonies to
update everyone you know about where
you're going where you're taking the
product where you're taking your team
where you think you need to go
and that is the only way to grow if you
don't do that
then suddenly you know the companies
start to split into different directions
and and you lose direction
so but i'm guessing also it's not the
same it's not the same level of
communication that you have with your
leadership team as with the entire
company right because i'm assuming that
you know there's two challenges here one
is to grow the company and and now
now talk and now communicate with 200
people but you also have the
the issue of you now have 10 executives
versus you had maybe three or four
before and now you have to use that over
communication to align the executives
who are then need to align the different
segments of the company especially in
different time zones around the world
exactly and executives have opinion
right they are tasked to lead to lead
strategy
right they they need to take their team
to the right place we trust them to do
that we empower them to do that
right so there is an inherent conflict
here
of you know everyone going to the same
direction and at the same time have
independence and lead their team so it
becomes a lot more complicated when you
become big and there are a lot of very
opinionated
talented people right that each need to
take their
functions to the right places and that
is a huge challenge
if you're looking back at some of the
toughest times you've had at incest and
i'm sure that there were a bunch of
tough times as with any good
entrepreneurial story where did you
derive your your personal inspiration
from who did you turn to what did you
think of when you were really stuck in a
rut and you're like wow i need help
getting out of this
yeah
so i think
for me every time i came into this
situation i really hang on to my
co-founders
so every time that i felt like wow
it would be impossible to win the market
right and be one of the best solutions
in the market
you know i had one of my co-founders
telling me story hey i actually met
today customer and he loved us
right hey i actually talked to customer
success manager today and he told me
that we made a huge jump in the last six
months in the product and he has now
confidence that we're going to be number
one
so i really hang on to my founders every
time that one of us you know had this
situation
that was extremely challenging
you know having like the the other
person telling me hey actually from my
point of view you know things are good i
see the light
that really
gave me strength and my co-founder as
well
it gave us strength all over all over
our journey
did did that relationship and that
intimacy stay
throughout the seven years were you as
close in your seventh year as you were
in your first year
yeah
so i think we're
as good friends as we started uh
so um
like until today
we hang out together even after work and
we have a very very good relationship
but i can tell you that through the
journey it's ups and downs all the time
so it's not not the same level all the
time
and we had our conflicts
around recruitment around strategy
around funding
which investors we want to take how much
we want to raise when do we want to
raise
these big questions create a lot of
conflicts
so while we kept good friends they were
ups and downs i think the secret
for at least for us was
that every time we had a conflict every
time we argued every time we even
screamed at each other
the day later we only we need to
continue
to make this work
we need to continue together because the
success of this company depends on us
and the day later we acted like friends
even if we screamed at each other like
the evening before the next day
like nothing has happened we continue to
build this company
well i can only wish for myself that in
whatever company i try to build i remain
that close with my co-founders and i
have that same healthy relationship of
of acknowledging the ups and downs but
knowing that at the end of the day we're
partners and we're going to get through
this and and i love what you said about
that somebody always sees the light and
and there's it's so it feels like it's
almost like a shifting responsibility
okay now you're it's your turn to see
the light and i'm going to be the one
who's going to complain and and you're
just going to tell me that you see the
light and and i cannot i can just
imagine that round table conversation
and how inspiring that is and i really
want to thank you for joining me in
these 20 minutes i had a a phenomenal
time and it sounds like a really really
cool fun and exhilarating journey
obviously ending in in a huge upside for
everybody a huge pride for the israeli
ecosystem so thank you for for all the
hard work and i have one last question
for you alone if you were to think of a
few words that you would use to describe
yourself what words would you choose
yeah um
so i think the the first one would be
relentless
you know i i face challenges all the
time
but i always continue with my goals with
my targets and push ahead even if i have
downs i always get up and continue i
think that's what brought me you know to
the point where i'm in today
on top of that i would say optimistic
i'm an optimistic guy i believe that
things
would work
uh that the end would be good
and that gives me a lot of drive and
that also empowers people who work with
me
and and people that i lead
so i think that gives gives me the
ability to lead them ahead and give them
belief and and optimism
and the last maybe the last one i would
say
i know builder or creator
because this is why i wake up in the
morning uh to build new things to create
things that
didn't exist before
and that is my greatest passion
for this for this time for the these 20
minutes but for the seven years and for
for what you're doing now with rapid
seven and even bigger todah for the
amazing work that that you went that he
did with the community both in the
financial literacy and cyber literacy um
it's it's inspiring for me as young
entrepreneur to see that and to see you
know that you can do both you can only
be very successful be very determined
but also give back uh not just with
money but with time and with energy
and so stay safe and stay healthy and
thank you very much
thank you i enjoyed every minute of this
conversation
thank you bye lon